[Music]
reading also fully justified font is
this a movie or a newspaper team
Hollywood Brooke who shoots for realism
on the singing but goes CG for the
scenery well at least the movies honest
severe is wearing a night cap
movie only waits three minutes to start
in with the Jesus imagery go time is up
and your paroles bigger wait then why
was he singing along with all the other
prisoners about having to serve 20 more
years follow to the letter your
artillery itinerary
now John wasn't kidding when he said his
old self died his teeth even turn from
yellow to white no one helps the mayor
lift this pink cart off this poor
bastard
no not the face not the voice it's the
lifting by which you remember a man
they know what she's got they must have
seen Love & Other Drugs and havoc and
Brokeback Mountain so they're like
Catherine zeta-jones
[Music]
[Applause]
personally I think the amateur novocaine
free tooth polling would be much more
traumatic than having sex with a
stranger yeah but have you seen autumn
she's pretty hot
nobody in this movie can recognize
anybody else for how many days are
supposed to pass and she got fired like
one right do we even have any idea
what's wrong with her like if she's sick
injured fast-acting STD Oscar in hand an
Hathaway exits and doesn't appear again
until the end of the film four hours
later you just asked her twice already
okay the casting director must have
watched Sweeney Todd and then said I
want all these actors come for the
lavish musical production numbers stay
for the refined food drinking bags oh
[Music]
okay if you say so this hat is magical
because he takes it off and then it's
right back on his head
Valjean lowers his new daughter back
down from the roof by rope and then
drops the rope how the hell's he gonna
get down now I fell under my cars you
saved my life was you oh well that's
convenient Ken Russell Crowe just also
died while we're at it
Otten fallen
[Music]
they must have shot this scene first and
then said well we've already blown a
million dollars on this set so I guess
we'll have to keep Russell Crowe in this
movie I never knew so many French people
spoke with an English accent whose is
one of those French Revolutions no it's
the June rebellion
nothing lasted two days but the one for
Victor Hugo this would be a slightly
bloody or Occupy Wall Street how about a
magic track I'm gonna make this
disappear yeah forget the super hot
brunette this random blonde girl is way
hotter Sacha Baron Cohen imitates Adam
Sandler's opera man jeez all this wine
no wonder the rebellion got crushed in
two days is it better than this opera
because I'd like to see that as that
leaves a house late at night in her
nightgown after a fight with her fake
dad and her fake dad doesn't think
anything of it
in other words Cosette is great and
you're hideous I don't know how you can
seem so surprised at how things worked
out yet another movie girl that's
perfectly happy to have been stalked as
we all know butterflies are extremely
attracted to love this dude still wants
our after hearing your sink
even after filming the scene the
director still thought the live singing
gimmick was a good idea oh nothing just
singing with the creepers then I'll
arrange our passage to England he's had
Gazette for 10 years and has only just
now thought of leaving France to escape
Javert with so many people singing at
once I'm having a hard time deciding who
to ignore so their protest is to
interrupt a funeral parade honoring a
guy they love well sure let's just trust
this random stranger for this revolution
we've been planning for ages mahjong
goes from worried about Marius stealing
his daughter away too desperate to keep
Marius alive so that he can steal coz it
away in like two seconds Jean Valjean
may be the luckiest mother forever how
was this asshole caught stealing a loaf
of bread again dude life without Cosette
has been your whole life up until today
[Music]
so the kid is responsible for keeping
the revolution alive also does this kid
have any parents who cares why are a
bunch of mostly grown Frenchmen so
easily swayed by a little orphan kid
with more cockney in his accent than
Oliver Twist finally some decent
parenting
how ironic they're now lying in the
stuff they've been making for two hours
this guy down here has he been waiting
for Jean Valjean and Marius to fall down
the sewer the whole time his sins be
forgiven I know this movie sins won't be
forgiven mash was wrong suicide is not
painless how does this guy know where
Valjean is what is he dying from again
does anyone in this movie actually die
from anything or did they just run out
of time or something oh I don't know I
think most of the audience said goodbye
20 minutes ago
[Music]
new pop eight years forget Stowe's there
oh sure
[Music]
the trees it's like hey they totally
stole this song from Susan Boyle